BIZEAR-A-LAGO LASTON'TUS CLASSI
S  SECRETS
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.FTS,N PRESO
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SAYS  11N
TRUMS SS.
NOW FOUR WEEKS A MAR-A-LAGO 64%
MONSTERS CONTROLLED BY RADICAL
LEFT SCOUNDRELS,AWYERS ANDMEDIAT
U PELE --
AND WHEN IT.
NG T
TLY, THEARNG TE YOU.ILL NOILENC.
>> NOW ALL THESE
HAPPENING HERE?YOU REEDDIRMATH,G
SOMEN SUPPORT FOR
NALD TRUMP
WHAT JIM BANKSD  Y I
CHCAUCUS IN T TO YOU
RUN SOONHAS SAIDE WOULD BE ASD F
MYD UPREADY TOO AND RECEIVED A
NY YOU CHOSE TTONED A LOSI T
REFEREAT WAS O 9th A
AFTEE ARAS
IDENT'SILAST WEEK I CHECKED IN
LOT OF REPUBLICAN SOURCES
INCLUDG S AND
ADVISERS WHO WERE G HIM HR 202ES
PRESSURE  THMIDT.
WAIT UNTIL HE'S FID OUT JUST IN.
JUMPING IN
HEN BL
PASTWO WEEKS AS
WED THIS DRIP,P
OF INFTIUT
CLASSIFIEDUMENTS,
THAT THEWE BEING STORED AT
SO JUST EMPTY
BOXE DOCUMENTS ISTERCT WHETHER
E
OBRUTHT'A AL CONCERN.
AJOR LEG C
TH REPCA
IS T
ISA PATTERN WE'VE SEEN
IDWHS SA
OPLE WHONKS
THIS IS SERIOU T'SERTT
BARR IN FACT,  SORT OFOFOXES NOL
KNN THEM
Y ASSIFY  IN RE SUC ABUSE ANDS .
HISITION IS VNTO
THINDEFEME KEYS.
>> THAT'S
I THINK FOR THE FORMERRESIDENT
THERE ARE TWO QUESTIONS AND ONE
IS HUCBLE IS H
?
HOW MUCH POLITICAL TROUBS
HODAIS GOING TO BE
HR DESIRE TO LEAD
THE Y  BA TU
FOR PRESIDENT AG
INTERSECT AT SOMPOIN THE L  IS
IT ANSWERS THEITICALQUTIEN I T .
E AS
YOU SFRAUAWY LAST
JUST COMING FOR ME THEY'RE
COMING FOR Y RY TH.
'SHAS
WITH WHETHER OR NOT HE IS EVER A
IN.
PRESIDENAGPENDS ASE IS GOING IN
MEASURE.
>>THTICAL FRONT
THERE'S A CLEAY HERE AO
CLASSIFIED INFORMATICOLL
>> WAL NST
PROTECTION O
ATION.WORST SITUATION.
LLE EMAI
OUR EN DISQUALIFIES
CNME U JBOLT6.
JAMES EN CALLED FONALTY.
HE EVELAO
AGAINST PELE MISHANDLEORAN D TO
OR LOOKING
IT IN 24 E,  MUCH MORE THAS
TO COME OUR O RE KNOW WHAT THE N
MIDTERMS, AND HE'S OBVIOUSLY
RE
HE'S INDICATEDPROBABLY WON'T
THE EFFECT OEA
MAR-A-LAGO AND THIS WHOLSTORYLI
E DEMOCRATS SORT D HIM D IFE WE
THIS MOMENT BIDEN, TO OTHE
ALREADY THE FACE OF THE THESE T
IT HAS ALREADY A
POLITI ON THNGT'Y
HODEMOCRATS, TOO
ER
ATTACHINLY ANYUBCAHE KIND , QUO
EVEN TO THE POINT SOMES ARE S W
WINNING THESS AS WELOF